you're talking to a largely libertarian
audience and on libertarian social media
this week There's Been various clips of
Ron Paul circulating around and I wanted
to play one of those to open up that
conversation about what the US role in
Israel and Palestine has been and should
be moving forward so let's roll that
clip of Ron Paul from 2001 voting
against a um uh a sort of re voting
against a resolution that would have
condemned uh a Palestinian bombing of
Israel at the time uh and he was the
sole Republican to vote against that and
this was the speech he gave in support
of his vote so let's roll
that we hear today talk about being
having solidarity with Israel and others
get up and and try in their best way to
defend the Palestinians and and the
Arabs so it's sort of a contest should
we be pro-israel or pro-arab or
anti-israel or anti-arab and how do we
how are we seen and doing this and it's
pretty important but I think there's a
third option to this that we so often
forget about why why can't we be
pro-american what is in the best
interest of the United States we haven't
even heard that yet I believe that it's
in the best interest of the United
States not to get into a fight a fight
that we don't have the wisdom to figure
out now I would like to have neutrality
that's been the tradition uh for America
at least a century ago to be friends
with everybody trade with everybody and
to be neutral unless somebody declares
war against us but not not to demand
that we pick sides now I have a proposal
and a suggestion which I think fits the
American tradition that we should treat
both sides
equally but in a different way today we
treat both sides equally but by giving
both sides money and telling them what
to do not a million dollars here or
there not a hundred million here or
there but tens of billions of dollars
over decades always trying to buy peace
and my argument is that it generally
doesn't work that there are unintended
consequences these things backfire they
come back to haunt us so I think we
should start off by defunding defunding
both sides I I'm just not for giving all
this money because every time there are
civilians
killed on the Israeli side or civilian
killed on the Palestinian side you can
be assured that either our money was
used directly or indirectly to do that
killing so we are in a way an accomplice
on all this because we fund both sides
the policy of foreign
non-intervention where the United States
is not the bully
it doesn't come in and tell everybody
exactly what to do and put these demands
on if we didn't do that yes we could we
could have some moral authority to come
condemn violence but should we not
condemn violence equally could it be
true that only innocent civilians have
died on one side and not the other I
don't believe that to be true I believe
that it happens on both sides and on
both sides they use our money to do this
I urge a no vote on this
resolution what do you think of Ron
Paul's idea that America would be better
off and actually so would Israel and
Palestine if the US just cut off Aid Al
together uh to both
sides what I would say is probably not
directly answer that but I would say
that so far
I think that the Biden
response has been good I think that the
attack was just
appalling and I think that the
administration unlike honestly a lot of
people around the world have
recognized how horrible the violence
was the United States to the best of my
understanding has told Israel that it
will support it with the Iron Dome that
it that basically you need to replenish
the stocks and it's very expensive
because its adversaries have so many of
these these rockets and that the United
States will provide assistance which is
defensive assistance in that area and
that I also support I was surprised to
to see this but such a swift a swift
dispatch um to the Eastern Mediterranean
as a deterrent again I think that that's
strategic and although the Pauls might
disagree and think that that's too much
American involvement um it comes at very
low cost for the United States and could
actually save money and prevent future
incentives which
could increase the risk of embroiling
the United States more um in a wider
Middle East conflict so in my mind those
are the three main responses of the
Biden Administration it's been
rhetorical it's been for defensive um
Weaponry especially with the Iron Dome
and then also moving the ship closer to
um hollah uh to warn Hezbollah and Iran
and I believe that us diplomats have
been into touch um with both of those
International actors telling them
warning them that the United States
could um get involved so thus far from
what I've seen um I have uh approval and
I'm not sure that um the Biden
administration's response has
necessarily rankled um those who are
sympathetic to a more libertarian
approach to foreign policy yeah what
about this that what about this point
that um that sort of pouring money into
the region over the years H with under
this pretense that you know it's G to
get in the right hands and it's going to
be used in a way that advances us
interests in the region that it just
hasn't worked out that way um you know
there's been since it's Inception about
a quarter of a trillion dollars gone
into Israel
several tens of billions to Palestine
about half a billion to Palestine since
the B Administration took power and you
know we don't know how that money has
been used presumably at least some of it
has been used to obtain Rockets or
weapon other weapons to go into Israel
um I
mean I know we're in the midst of a
fight right now that it's it's hard to
it might be hard to think about these
questions but going forward is that
something that needs to be rethought the
amount of Aid that's the US Aid and
weapons going into the
region I mean I want to provide a little
bit of context here and that is when it
came to the origins of you know an
Israeli State and Us levels of support
for Israel the US ended up supporting um
Israel not for strategic reasons for
humanitarian reasons in the aftermath of
the Holocaust as well as domestic
political reasons because of course you
know some prominent American Jews were
very much in favor of Truman recognizing
Israel us support for Israel stayed
relatively low until after the Six Day
War it wasn't immediate it but after
that there was the so-called War of
Attrition around
1970 and at that point really shown in
The Six Day War but it took a little
couple years you can see a major major
uptick and US military support for
Israel and all of a sudden Israel was
seen as um not just worthy of support
for domestic reasons or humanitarian
reasons but as a strategic Ally in the
context of the Cold War and Israel did
Israel was useful strategically to the
United States in the Cold War as the
main us proxy in the Middle East you
know the Soviets had them on their side
and and the US had Israel on its side
when the Cold War
ended the Case for
Israel um became harder to make
for for for groups like APAC because
they had been used to selling Israel as
a strategic asset in the context of the
Cold War and then what made it even
tougher was you know a decade a little
more than a decade after the Cold War
ended you had the the 911 attacks where
Osama Bin Laden you know listed a whole
lot of reasons for why he attacked us
but one of them
um was essentially uh us relations um
with Israel and so increasingly it
seemed that American citizens were
wondering well you know what do we get
out of this deal not only is Israel no
longer a strategic asset but it might
even be a
liability the one of the reasons why I
think that the US has had such a strong
relationship with Israel beyond the
typical causal
explanations you know domestic American
Support um uh sympathy shared values Etc
all that is something really simple and
that is that in general Israel has
shared very similar enemies as the
United States and so when the When when
when when when DC thinks of who its
enemies are they're often really similar
to the enemies which are shared um in in
Jerusalem and we see that working with
respect to us relations with Saudi
Arabia you the you know terrible
relations um with Iran um and I think
that there's a lot of sort of emotional
value which translates into support at
least at the policy level um by having a
lot of the same Mutual enemies and and a
lot of the enemies actually make it easy
because they'll actually say death to
Israel death to America and it creates a
a very sort of easy opening for people
like Lindsey Graham to say not only do
we have shared enemies but we therefore
have you know shared interests in that
essentially like Nikki Haley might
suggests an attack on Israel is is you
know is an attack on America um but I
just wanted to provide a little bit of
context to listeners in terms of how we
got to this point in terms of the
trajectory of us support for Israel hey
thanks for watching that clip from our
conversation with Max Abrams about
hamas's attack on Israel for another
clip click here for the full
conversation click here